if the CW's crisis on Infinite Earths
crossover left you a little confused
don't worry you're not alone the good
news is that we're here to sort out a
few of its more convoluted aspects and
explain just what's going on and why
who exactly is the guy who shows up in
purgatory and bestows seemingly
unfathomable cosmic powers on Oliver
Queen he identifies himself as Jim
Corrigan the spectre but if you haven't
had your nose buried in DC Comics for
the better part of your life that
probably didn't answer any questions
despite being a relatively obscure
character The Spectre is a favorite for
this kind of world shattering event
because he's the literal embodiment of
the wrath of God he's less of a person
and more of a force of nature a vessel
for divine fury with cosmic power even
Superman could only imagine
unfortunately it turned out that turning
God's vengeance into a person without
any mitigating force could lead to some
abuses of power to temper his vengeance
and create a new superhero in 1940 the
presents found the specter to Jim
Corrigan a cop who had been killed by
criminals returning him to life as a
ghostly superhero eventually Corrigan
worked off enough of his sins that he
was allowed to move on to his final
reward and the spectre force was passed
down to others after his death Green
Lantern Hal Jordan was the spectre for a
while and then Gotham City detective
Chris Allen was drafted into the job
it's never been handed off to Oliver
Queen in the comics but the fact that
both characters wear costumes built
around green hoods makes the shift in
wardrobe and an easy one most heroes
only get one chance to sacrifice their
lives to save the world
Oliver Queen got to once as Green Arrow
fighting to the death against the anti
monitors army of Shadows and then again
as the spectre seemingly sacrificing his
life to end the threat to the multiverse
the ante monitors death didn't really
stick though so is Oliver really dead
I told you dying is easy part the answer
most likely is a frustrating one yes and
no Oliver is definitely dead
he's the specter and as the name implies
the specter is quite literally a ghost
that said as far as superheroes are
concerned death is not a permanent state
the real question is whether Oliver
Queen will stick around in his new
phantasmal form and the answer to that
is probably if he's the spectre that
means he's beyond the traditional
boundaries of life and death
meaning that he has a pretty good chance
of coming back as the driving force of a
future CW crossover if Stephen Amell
ever gets bored with whatever he's going
to do after eight seasons of arrow with
a distinct possibility he'll jump into
professional wrestling one of the major
selling points for the CW crisis was
that it included nods to the entire
history of DC Comics films and TV shows
some like the Smallville scene or the
visit to earth 99 were pretty relevant
to the plot while others were basically
just cameos and they might have gone by
too fast for viewers who don't have vast
portions of who's who in the DC Universe
memorized to keep up with this is
another reference to the original crisis
on Infinite Earths comic which also
opens with the destruction of a handful
of DC's long-standing parallel worlds
complete with the red skies and fade to
white while the comic starts off by
obliterating earth 3 the show opens up
with two incarnations of the Dark Knight
being wiped out of existence earth 89
and earth 66 setting the trend of
Earth's mostly being numbered the years
that they debuted neither of the earths
the event opens with actually show that
world's version of its main character
bat men on earth 89 we catch up with the
intrepid reporter Alex NOx and Danny
Elfman's classic score letting us know
we're in the world of the 1989 Batman
film after that we skip over to the
decidedly retro earth 66 where Burt Ward
appears with a color scheme that lets us
know we're seeing the robbing of the
classic Batman TV series hey
we also see the Huntress running around
on rooftops on earth 203 a reference to
the birds of prey series which aired its
single season back in 2003 there are a
few notable exceptions to the year rule
though for instance we see a Superman
killed by Lex Luthor on earth 75 it's
actually a reference to a single comic
the shot of Superman and Lois that we
see on the news is lifted from 1994 s
Superman 75 the climax of the famous
death of Superman's story in which the
Man of Steel was killed by doomsday when
the Superman of Earth 96 joins up with
the crew there are a few jokes made
about how weird it is that he looks
exactly like Ray Palmer although no one
ever bothers to give a reason why the
obvious real-world reason is that both
characters are played by Brandon Ralph
who starred as the Man of Steel in 2006
as Superman Returns Superman 96 is
pretty clearly meant to be the same
Superman played by Christopher Reeve in
the 1978 Superman film and it's three
sequels and Ralph has played that
character before Superman Returns was
meant to pick up after Superman 2
ignoring the last two movies when he
sees Lois we get a brief excerpt of can
you read my mind the love theme from
Superman the movie and then there's this
line actually
this is the second time I've done
nothing for myself that's a callback to
Superman 3 where Superman splits into
Clark Kent and Superman to fight himself
in a junkyard
but why is he on earth 96 and not earth
206 or earth 78 Ralph's Man of Steel
isn't just from the movies it's also a
clear reference to Mark Waid in Alex
Ross's landmark 1996 comics miniseries
Kingdom Come the deaths of Lois Lane and
the rest of the Daily Planet staff at
the hands of the Joker are lifted from
that story as is the black and red
emblem that Superman wears in mourning
one of the grimmest moments of crisis on
Infinite Earths comes when Supergirl and
Batwoman take a visit to earth 99 Kevin
Conroy best known for his starring role
in Batman the Animated Series starting
in 1992 plays a version of Batman who is
given into his darkest impulses Bruce 99
appears to be in an incredible amount of
pain both mental and physical but we
don't get a lot of details as to what
happened to make him this way he does
mention that his world's version of Cate
Kane had been killed in action as that
woman helping push him over the edge
Luke Fox tells Supergirl that many of
his injuries are the result of his fight
with Superman though that doesn't seem
to be the entire truth of the matter
like Superman 96 Bruce 99 takes his look
from Kingdom Come where he's depicted
wearing a similar exoskeleton in their
annotations to that story Wayde and Ross
told readers that there was no single
event that caused this level of injury
and that it was just the toll of years
and years of getting in multiple
fistfights with Gotham's weirdest
villains the 99 by the way is probably a
reference to Batman Beyond which
premiered in 1999 and where Conroy
voiced in older Bruce who was a bit worn
down but not villainous in recent memory
Tom Welling has played Clark Kent longer
than anyone else starring in 10 seasons
of Smallville but he only once dawn
Superman's red and blues throughout the
show's run so it makes sense that when
the heroes of the arrowverse catch up
with Smallville's Clark on earth 167 he
still isn't Superman much to Lex
Luthor's disgust
Clark actually gave
his powers to focus on starting a family
with Lois you gave up your powers can't
say I miss these chats you are basically
a god you could fly this particular plot
point seems to be loosely inspired by
Alan Moore and Kurt swans whatever
happened to the man of tomorrow the
final Superman story before the end of
the original crisis on Infinite Earths
comics in that story it's revealed that
Superman gave up his powers by exposing
himself to gold kryptonite which
permanently strips Kryptonians of their
metahuman abilities it's pretty safe to
assume that Smallville's Clark did the
same especially since gold kryptonite
was introduced in Smallville's last
season the comic book crisis on Infinite
Earths streamlines DC's comic book
multiverse which had spread out over
worlds including earth to earth 3 Earth
X Earth C earth C minus and so on
into one single universe the TV version
has done the same putting the main CW
shows into one cohesive earth Prime one
of the reasons that DC had such a
convoluted multiverse is that unlike
their competition at Marvel where the
universe and many of its core characters
had been created by a relatively small
group of people and focused mainly on
New York the DC universe was much more
of a patchwork the characters had mostly
been created in isolation
sometimes by different publishers who
were acquired by DC after the fact the
same goes for the show's arrow came
first and spun off directly into flash
legends of tomorrow and Batwoman
but Supergirl originally aired on CBS
and was completely separate from the CW
shows until a crossover established it
as a parallel world Black Lightning
started off on the CW but it was set in
a different universe in hopes of
establishing its lesser-known hero
outside of the shadow of the other
characters with Supergirl flash Batwoman
legends of tomorrow Black Lightning and
arrow now combined into the newly
christened earth prime there's a shared
history creating a world where all the
characters exist alongside each other so
after eight years of arrow
we finally have a world where Superman
and Batman coexist with the other heroes
finally making the DC TV universe feel
whole characters can interact without
the need for another world
during interdimensional crossover I mean
how often does the world almost come to
an end almost like that so it's likely
that we could see more instances of the
shows crossing over in the future it's a
lot easier to have the flash hang out
with Supergirl Winn he doesn't have to
vibrate to a parallel world the DC TV
multiverse has been at the center of
several crossovers that have become an
annual tradition a major character on
the flash Harrison wells is built
entirely around swapping out with his
own interdimensional counterparts every
now and then forcing for Tom Cavanagh to
do a new accent every couple of months
while ostensibly playing the same guy
with that mind it seems like the show's
would be giving up a lot of potential
stories with everything combined into
the new earth Prime
but unlike the comic the show's didn't
actually ditch the idea of the
multiverse the main CW shows have all
been added to a single earth with the in
story reason being that they're the home
worlds of the seven Paragon characters
who saved the entirety of existence but
there are plenty of other worlds out
there in addition to confirming that the
DC films are a part of this multiverse
through a surprise cameo from movie
flash Ezra Miller it also preserves some
of the other shows the show streaming on
DC Universe make it through with Earth's
9 19 and 21 being established as the
settings for Titans Swamp Thing and Doom
Patrol respectively earth 96 is shown to
survive with Brandon Roth's older
Superman and we also see earth 12 hinted
at being the setting for HBO max's
upcoming Green Lantern show for longtime
comic book readers the most interesting
reveal might be the all-new earth 2
which will be the home of the upcoming
star girl show in the comics earth 2 was
the home of the original Golden Age
heroes of the Justice Society of America
who debuted in the 40s and as time went
on their descendants star girl herself
was a reimagining of one of those earth
two characters the star-spangled kid and
with the show drawing on the histories
of JSA characters such as Wildcat and
dr. midnight setting it there makes a
lot of sense it allows her world
have a different history playing into
the idea of legacy that's so core to her
character without interfering with the
new history of earth Prime while the
original comics crisis is largely known
as the crossover that got rid of earth
to the TV version is one that has
introduced it to a whole new generation
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belt so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]